diehard Trump supporters in Orlando more
than 24 hours before the rally they were
already camping out here
the sisters Maureen and Laureen told us
they barely slept to get into the first
room we wanted to see her president up
close we've been to other rallies but to
us this is a historical event to be at
his campaign kickoff most of the rally
goers voted for Trump in 2016 and are
eager to do so again we support
president Trump because he's fulfilled
everything that he promised to do and
that's he's a man of his word and we we
believe that true leadership comes from
being a man of your word it's important
for me to be here to bring attention to
a basically an election issue that I
support I support barriers on America
southern border primarily to keep
illegal narcotics and human trafficking
out Florida was crucial to president
Trump's 2016 election victory and he
still seems to be quite popular here but
despite a growing economy and low
unemployment the Trump campaign is
facing a tough path to re-election it's
internal polling data shows Trump behind
top Democratic contenders in key states
and just relying on his core supporters
might be not enough to pull off another
victory in November next year but this
night was all about optimism and the
will to win
when Donald Trump took the stage in elem
tonight I stand before you to officially
launch my campaign for a second term I
can promise you that I will never ever
let you down I won't tax cuts boosting
military spending judicial appointments
in Orlando Trump touted what he called
his great achievements at the same time
he attacked his political opponents
demonstrating how much his campaign
appears to rely on US versus them
rhetoric no matter what label they use a
vote for any Democrat in 2020 is a vote
for the rise of radical socialism and
the destruction of the American Dream
words that occurred the anger and
passion of Trump's 2016 campaign and
went down well with his core supporters
in Florida some familiar topics that
we've heard there let's break it down
Boris Johnson Boris Foreman excuse me
joins us now he is a professor of
politics at Bard College in Berlin Boris
welcome to the program as always so you
know we've we've heard you know topics
from Donald Trump there in Orlando
Florida including migration how likely
do you think it is that this might be
one of the main themes that he he drives
forward in this campaign well I mean
some people were expecting this to be a
starting point for his campaign maybe
also content-wise this is not what he
delivered as you said I mean there were
no issues that he brought to the table
that were in any way new he's been
campaigning all the time basically
during his presidency it was also not
really an announcement that he would run
for reelection because he did that just
on the day of his inauguration on
January 20th 2017 so in some way it was
a non-event but in other ways yes I mean
he he he presented those topics that are
dear to him and that we will probably
see again all the wild until then the
elections next year we have to talk
about the poll results for him
controversial also
you know some contradictory polling
results in states like Ohio Pennsylvania
Florida these are states which are
really important for him right right
these are the key states the swing
states where he's lagging he's also the
only president who's never made it to be
more proofed and disapproved in his
popularity rankings but nonetheless I
mean we should be careful with these
poll numbers many of my colleagues and I
were too reliant on these statistical
analyses before the last election and so
I think we shouldn't put too much of an
emphasis on these numbers just briefly
Boris before we go who do you think the
Democratic challenger will be and do
they stand a chance I'm also being
careful with prognosis generally
speaking because I was wrong the last
time I think the field is as broadened
as it as it has ever been I think it's
going to weaken the Democratic Party and
they should come to a conclusion as fast
as possible
Boris Foreman joining us thank you so
much thanks